so we're in a cardboard dome and in the
middle of the dome there's a
non-directional
director and with the projector is a
camera in the camera can basically cents
our hand gestures over the projector and
so right now we're looking at is
worldwide telescope data we're looking
to 3d model the solar system and then as
I gesture over the over the projector I
can move the view and so what we're
doing here is actually we're trying to
explore different modes of interaction
that makes sense for on the directional
and 3d data and what we'd like to do is
to take some of the interactions that
have been successful with surface and
bring them into this on the directional
setting and so we can hold the view and
pan around this 3d data but the way that
we zoom is this kind of familiar to
multi touch users of surface for example
so if I have two contacts or make use
two hands I can move in and out of the
view we're driving the world wide
telescope program and we can move the
view with our hands then we were doing
that is we're doing some simple image
processing on an image produced by a
camera that's embedded with the
projector so we can do we can basically
grab the view we grab the sky and move
around so looking at the 3d solar system
model provided by worldwide telescope
you can also zoom in
some standard surface like multi-touch
gestures couple of the things we can do
gear if I make a special gesture over
the projector we can then give it a
speech command Saturn so it's now taking
us to Saturn then we can even move in on
the rings of Saturn get a nice view of
what's going out there and then we can
zoom out and the course worldwide
telescope has a very nice model of all
the stars and even galaxy so we can keep
zooming out zooming out and we get this
this nice effect there's the milky way
through the Milky Way now we're these
are all galaxies
so the dome gives you a really nice
immersive fuel and we think that it's
suited really for all the directional
data and 3d data so another thing we can
do is worldwide telescope is we can show
you the night sky Crab Nebula so this is
true I'm directional day that's not a 3d
model it's a way of looking at imagery
saved from the Hubble Space Telescope
this is the Crab Nebula and again we can
move in and out and do the same kinds of
gestures these gestures are familiar to
surface users these are basically
multi-touch gestures and in fact many of
the techniques are similar we show you a
few other things that we can deal with
snow globe demo this is just the fun
little demo that shows you what it might
be like if you were inside of a snow
globe and it gives you a nice 3d sense
what's going on braf demo here is a
social networking graph and so we're
thinking about looking at different ways
manipulating 3d data and visualizing
different kinds of information so the
idea might be that we we can point and
gesture if we have multiple people in
the dome we can relate to this kind of
data in an interesting way again we're
using the same kinds of gestures to to
move in and out of the space
actually I'd like to show a couple of
other panoramas telescope demo let the
move back into worldwide telescope
building 99 so this is a panorama that's
hosted in worldwide telescope it's
actually of building 99s lobby so again
the omnidirectional projector gives you
a wonderful sense of immersion now right
now we're doing these little hand
gestures right over the projector
eventually we'd like to do more kinds of
things so if i want to point directly at
the display theoretically we can do that
because the camera just like the
projector you can see everywhere in the
dome above the equator line